hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
the Biden Administration is still
screwing everything up a growing number
of U.S companies say that they are
planning to lay off workers a lot of
uncertainty over the future of jobs in
this country some major companies
already announcing Cuts including Ford
cutting 3 000 jobs now a new survey
finds more than half of all major
companies in the U.S are planning
layoffs in the coming months while 52
percent are preparing for hiring freezes
44 percent plan to rescind job offers
Fox Business correspondent Jackie
Angeles joins us now Jackie great to see
you good to see you this is this is
scary to hear because the one thing and
the White House likes to tout this that
has been holding out and this economy
has been the jobs market we've been able
to see there's millions of open jobs out
there and if somebody wants a job they
can certainly go find one is that
changing it seems to be changing and
I've been saying this is the next shoe
to drop right so last week I was talking
about some of the layoffs that we've
seen in Tech and let me just go over
some of the big names with you either
slowing hiring or laying people off
alphabet Amazon Apple Microsoft meta
Netflix Peloton Tesla Twitter the tone
out there from CEOs is that there are
headwinds coming we're bracing for that
we're trying to anticipate it and be
ready for it then you hear from the
retailers like Target Walmart Best Buy
Lowe's Gap TJ Maxx they're all either
warning or they're lowering their profit
guidance this has been a fun summer
everyone's been out spending I'm telling
you after Labor Day people are going to
have to come back and face some harsh
realities we're going to start to see
that impacted in the Market stock market
just realized it yesterday yeah you're
already seeing it I mean Ford that was a
that was a bit of a shocker right so
they're they're leaning in hard on going
in the EV route and so they're laying
off in other parts of their company 3
000 workers